we've been speaking today with dr. Peter
Bogosian full-time faculty member in
Portland State University's philosophy
department also author of the book a
manual for creating atheists Peter when
you take a sort of broader look as to
what's going on in American politics you
know everybody has their sort of general
assessment what put Trump in the White
House what does this mean for the future
of one political party or the other
political party stepping back from the
sort of day-to-day politics and firings
and scandals and whatever the case may
be do you agree with me that we are
increasingly separating the political
world from any sense of epistemology
critical thinking the importance of the
facts as we can know them over the last
I don't know six months five years ten
years like a unit are you on board with
me and that departure that we're seeing
univocal
we are speak as one voice absolutely
unshakably convinced of that what do you
attribute that to because there are
partisan people who say hey listen the
Democrats are the party effects and the
Republicans aren't so you've got a party
that in order to get elected is going to
move away from facts there's another
slightly more general view which is we
have growing pseudo and anti
intellectualism and that's what is
reinforcing to sort of pride in not
dealing with the facts I don't know I
mean what do you think we can point to I
know no so the rise of social media
anonymous accounts the fact that I I
know honestly I don't know I can only
hypothesize the answer to that I don't
know I do find the deep divides and the
inability to have conversation with
people and ending of friendships over
that in fact that's my next book is
about how to have conversations across
the divide impossible conversations I
think we need to take a look and work
collaboratively with people but in this
current political environment it's
almost impossible I think Trump is in I
don't even know the adjectives I can
describe for how unhinge he is I used to
think that that tense was worse I'm
reading that belief but I do think that
need to react the ability to have
conversations into the discourse I don't
know what's causing this intense
polarization I just can't answer that
question I mean the problem I have is
that everything you're saying is true
but sometimes what you're saying is loop
is used to point to both sides are just
as valid on every issue every opinion on
every issue has to be heard and as you
know when you talk about good
epistemologies and bad epistemology in
your book that's not the case and that's
where I think that the general
discussions about polarization often
lead us nowhere because they reinforce a
need for false balance on every issue no
that's a great question as a tradition
now first of all everybody has a
microphone so everybody's voice is equal
as mine is James Lindsey said to me the
most important thing for us to do in
this age is determine is to determine
whose voice doesn't matter whose voice
doesn't matter so everybody has a
microphone the Democrats have been held
hostage to identity politics which is
one of the worst things they had like a
complete failure to acknowledge that
many of their tactics and beliefs
particularly as it regards to identity
politics and intersectionality have been
directly responsible for the rise of
Trump I don't think it's the case that I
think we tend to paint with these broad
brushes I think that there the
Republicans do tend to be more anti
science and particularly in regard to
environmental issues and the problem
with that is that those are those might
be with us for a very very very long
time and there's something about what
Trump is doing environmentally now if
you were to put everything he's doing in
a basket of crazy versus the
environmental stuff you know decreasing
our standing in the world you name it
he's he's got that in spades in terms of
anything that's negative the
environmental stuff I think would over
weigh all of that and unless we can
figure out how to talk to ourselves or
talk with each other I don't think we're
I don't think the smearing the
name-calling I don't think any of that
stuff is productive and helping us solve
any I can't think of any problem in
which screeching at someone is either
going to make them more likely to change
their mind or to solve the problem
doctor even I'm going to go beyond that
we did not even have the ability we are
not even honest in our conversations
anymore because we're afraid if we make
one misstep or if we say one wrong thing
we're going to be branded as a racist or
bigoted as a homophobe I think these are
terrible problems in which we look
what's happening to Sam Harris you can't
even have conversations with people or
Dave Rubin you can't even ask certain
questions and if you do either people if
you veer from the orthodoxy then the
people on your own tribe will attack you
or if you say something that other
people find unpalatable they'll just
smear you in it is that is that I asked
Dave Rubin this last week is that as big
of a problem as some are making it out
to be like just as an example like for
example I share your concerns with a
radical elements of third wave feminism
intersectionality sort of these
unproductive versions of identity
politics the safeSpace trigger warning
stuff and as I put it to Dave Rubin I'll
put it to you can we agree on the
problem but also come to some better
understanding of the degree to which it
exists because I think that that's where
I differ more with folks like you and
Dave Rubin not as to whether these
issues are problematic but the degree to
which they exist and you I'm not sure I
understand in other words like how big I
guess let me rephrase it this way I
agree with you that every issue you
cited as a problem is a problem however
I'd likely hear more about how you
determine the degree to which it's a
problem and how prevalent it is because
I think that the example among the left
some of these issues they're problems
but the relatively isolated issues well
they're problems because one you have a
bunch of extraordinarily vocal people
who make it look like they're in the
majority but are probably still in the
minority correct and unfortunately right
gonna give you a great example so ITA
been on sabbatical for a year I teach
ethics
and if you really want to teach ethics
right if you truly want to get people to
challenge their moral views and question
things to think about their beliefs you
have to talk about hard issues you have
to talk about transgender bathrooms you
have to talk about factory farming you
have to talk about Peter as soon as the
Australian philosopher Peter singers
what should we do with people who have
IQs under 25 no one's willing to talk
about this stuff and they know they're
not willing to talk about this stuff
because they don't want to deal with the
complaints because students are so
brittle that they've never heard the
other side of the issue so I think it
depends where you are and what kind of
conversations you're having you know I
think it also depends upon the people
with whom you're speaking is there some
way that this could be dealt with at an
earlier point and the reason I'm asking
that question is specifically when we
see for example what's going on with
Texas textbooks and the total
elimination of critical thinking as a
course that is even available
hypothetically in high schools wouldn't
we attack the college issue more
successfully if there was critical
thinking being taught in high school and
why is it that it's overwhelmingly
Republicans that don't want it taught in
high school well one it's because
they're pretending to know something
they don't know like if you thought you
had the truth you wouldn't profit eyes
to anybody they'd come you could
rationally derive those principles on
your own if you honestly believe for
example in Christianity or whatever
superstition you have to believe in you
wouldn't need to do that so there is
definitely a component of Republicans
the Republican Party has more or less
been hijacked by and you can perfectly
see this in a way that plays out with
who Trump panders to his bad audience
has been hijacked by religious maniacs
and you see that manifest across the
board the left is also culpable in that
in terms of what they're doing in the
Academy there's something here at
Portland State University that was
amazing to me and that was excuse me
they had a speaking event in which
anybody could attend but whites were not
allowed to ask questions blew my mind I
asked my buddy who's in a pail
Court judge I said I can't believe this
is legal he said yeah it's totally legal
but it's a horrible idea because then
they could because then that would mean
that they would have to have situations
in which White's could present blacks
could attend the blacks weren't allowed
to ask any questions so I see this
that's why I think the term regressive
is good because we're regressing to
separate but equal we're regressing to
these points that hopefully we had
overcome but but evidently not I mean I
think it's an enormous problem and at
the root of the whole problem I think
that the thing that helps us to think
about this is we need to think about
these things in terms of this is a
secular religion they have all the
hallmarks of a secular religion they
have blasphemy they have speech
political correctness
they have original sin which is
privileged which is what we started this
episode is off so I think if we look at
it in terms of that we're really seeing
the emergence of another religion that's
the end of our time today we've been
speaking with dr. Peter Boghossian
full-time faculty member at Portland
State University's philosophy department
the book a manual for creating atheist
has been the subject of some of our
conversation today Peter always great to
talk to you thank you thank you very
much and we also have an app a FiOS a th
us app com that puts a lot of these
principles into action for how to have
effective conversations